well usually I'm not the touchy feely
talk about your emotions type but
with this I just had to be a big enough
person to admit that I need help
I guess this is what growing up feels
like
this is Court mandated therapy you
assaulted a woman oh
it's a sweeping
that of course is the always funny cow
pen and the CBS comedy How I Met Your
Mother starting tonight Cal pin is the
latest comedian to guest host The Daily
Show after Trevor Noah stepped down The
Daily Show airs on Comedy Central which
like CBS is part of Paramount Global Cal
pen welcome thank you thanks for having
me they're having a bromance with you
but I get the first question pretty
obvious you know this Show's 30 years
old now you're stepping in I mean you've
had quite the career not just in
entertainment what will tonight be like
uh tonight's incredible look The Daily
Show has been one of my favorite shows I
have the chance to merge my background
in public service with my love of comedy
and comedy news is probably the thing
I've loved the most over the years but
especially now right some of my some of
my favorites to be able to follow in
these footsteps like comedy newswise Jon
Stewart obviously incredible Trevor Noah
who you mentioned uh Tucker Carlson is
hilarious in this space you know in the
comedy news face and the satire so the
idea that the idea that we get to sort
of roast some of the headlines but still
inform people in in a way is uh is
pretty great and you have a very special
guest for your first sit down who is
that yeah I do so look Jokes Aside one
of the things I love about uh about this
format and the opportunity to reach
people who maybe aren't watching cable
news aren't reading the paper is that
you can inform and feel let them know
how they plug into something so I'm very
very proud that my first guest for the
week is uh the president of the United
States how about that first visit right
we have uh we have a clip actually from
there this is you asking President Biden
about transgender youth yeah
uh transgender kids is a really harder
day thing what's going on in Florida
is as my mother would say close to
sinful I mean it's just terrible what
they're doing it's not like you know a
kid wakes up one morning and says you
know
I decided I want to become a man or I
want to become a woman or I want to
change I mean what what what are they
thinking about here
they're human beings they love they have
feelings they have inclinations that are
I mean it just to me is
I don't know it's cruel and the way we
do it is we make sure we pass
legislation like we passed on same-sex
marriage you mess with that you're
breaking the law and you're going to be
held accountable
look at that you got a good listening
face there speaking thank you thank you
I learned from the best you know how'd
you get them to sit down uh you know I I
reached out and I think I I said uh what
I what I really mean which is that one
of the things about this format that I
think is an incredible opportunity uh is
to kind of flip the script a little bit
I think satire by its nature can be
cynical but it doesn't have to be and so
when I was a white house I had one of my
frustrations was talking to people who
didn't necessarily understand how they
could plug into the Civics process and I
felt very frustrated as a government
official not being able to properly
explain that so I thought look we have
this platform with the show would you be
willing to come on the show and have a
conversation about certainly Solutions
things you've worked on on behalf of
young people but also things that they
may be pushing you on that you haven't
done yet like people need to know your
your thought process and how their
activism or advocacy can actually move
the needle well let's face it you two
have history we do have a little history
yeah a little bit we have the same boss
yes
that and 2020 you had a cute little do
we have that shot of you and the
aviators oh yeah that was fun oh a lot
which is yeah look at that he rocks the
aviators that's his look that's his
go-to it's true they're tucked in the
inside we were inside so I didn't think
I was cool enough to put them on in the
Roosevelt room but I mean you kind of
leaned out a little bit while you were
the Obama Administration you took your
entire team to a strip club I didn't
take them to a strip club this was the
challenge was okay when I started
it's I I mean if had I said yes it would
have been a bigger story I think I was
getting my hair cut and there was a
there was a guy the guy who was cutting
my hair said you should bring your whole
White House office I own a tapas bar
and I'm on my phone not paying attention
I was like yeah man over you should
bring you should bring Barack bring
Brock to the tapas bar I'm like yeah
definitely and I'm I'm doing my emails
and then at the end he hands me his card
and I see that it says rodolfo's ladies
I was like okay well if he goes to
Politico with this store so
you know you guys have successfully
followed up on this franchise Harold and
Kumar people love it people are waiting
so I have to ask will we see another one
if it's up to me yes I would I would
absolutely love it it's it's uh you know
an incredible franchise John Cho
incredible at the Oscars last night yeah
I would love us to get back together for
our fourth movie we uh we have our 20
year anniversary coming up most people
saw those movies on DVDs so now that we
didn't have streaming in those movies
came out right Rosie didn't have legal
marijuana exactly so now the movie has
to be about something else entirely the
stakes are so low with weed now so
that's amazing so we shall see Cal pan
thank you so much thank you I would say
good luck hosting the Daily Show but
you're not gonna need it you're amazing
thank you tune in yeah it's a great
conversation yep you can watch Kyle
Penn's interview with President Biden
tonight on The Daily Show on Comedy
Central